do you guys know why I summoned you to
this arena no last one of you to survive
in this arena gets $10,000 right what's
up gamers welcome back to another mr.
B's gaming video today we have Chandler
hey Chris hey and Carl bazinga
so here's how it works I'm in creative
mode they're all into probably I'm gonna
spawn mobs like this and boom whichever
creeper you would have died you
literally would have lost there and
that's the gist of it last one to die
wins question yep can we sabotage maybe
later on look right now no savvy you
guys probably all need some gear I'll
hook you up all right there we go I'm
gonna start summoning Jimmy what if one
of my arrows accidentally hits Carl
right in between the eyes that is
sabotage oh I didn't mean to round
number one is the 10 of spiders they're
poisonous $1,000 is on the line boys
good thing my aim is freakin nice oh I'm
so good okay all right you guys easy you
guys survived round number one round two
is zombie pigmen big oh no Chris you
knew if you don't attack them they don't
attack I know I had I already have
Chandler be one with the pigment Chris
if you die this early on the road big
guys help Chris no don't help me I don't
need it weaken the pigments way so that
if he hurts us then he gets some trouble
Carl you're being a bad boy push them
forward push them closer - I got a gold
nugget I'm a penguin giggling I'm the
only one who took down the Pigman are
you entertained my live entertained for
round three you're gonna get normal
zombies psych it's witches oh crap Carl
run this is Round three we're going
until they die oh you hit me with an
arrow you ran in front of Mike
Chandler's hitting me with arrows
Chandler he really really ran in front
of me we're about to die because they
threw it I'm not just standing I'm sorry
you're crying you're a gene and Weavin
boys are everyone gather in the middle
important meeting yeah round four is
this oh boy oh that's a big boy after me
he's after me
I gotta go fast I think it's so ugly oh
oh it was so easy to take down
okay okay okay everyone go to a
different corner for round five all
right Chris do you want a wolf uh yes
but I don't have any bones do I
well too bad here's a rhinoceros
Chandler you don't need one you know I
have a dog oh thank you
someone someone home Chris I thought I
could get up on him and do a sword
battle but he has such a big hitbox
Chandler how you doing
why does my armor suck all right I
should probably fix that there you go
thank you Carl Carl I tried to grab Fat
Boy didn't work all right Chris time we
upgrade you yes sir please I only have
one heart after that yes yes yes you
deserve an upgrade all right on to next
round
oh cool all right so I don't know what a
vexes but they're so hard to kill come
here hmm doing that oh yeah
Chandler you deserve a prize for killing
that we are now on round seven your
prizes creepers oh man oh wait what they
go all right Chris I apologize I
apologize you deserve a real upgrade
here's the thing I forgot I had levers
up here to spawn mob so oh all right
let's do eight creepers Oh
okay while they're fighting how about we
spawn a Twitter skeletons oh yeah how
about we throw in 16 skeletons and 16
zombies I am poisoned by the I'm now on
fire cuz the teammate shot me how you
guys doing down there I'm slowly dying
from the Whizzer you guys look like
you're having fun
don't forget $10,000 is on the line
Karla's bouncing like Annie boy I'm
running this looks easy oh no you guys
are having too much fun time to spice it
up no they're absolutely I backed into
the lava
I have less hearts here's the thing guys
know I'm a spawn and army of creepers
over here whatever you do do not come
near this corner Oh God whatever you do
do not go near this door
feeling risky I like quarters now it's
not sabotage to lure the creepers
towards enemy
we blow them all up oh wait actually I
can just flip the switches up here no
don't instead don't you guys all
survived the first ten rounds how do you
feel great good have a magma cube oh why
is it so small hey buddy oh my friends
and I are partying there's so many
little boys you should spawn creepers
now since we're so distracted with the
hard to hit magma cubes
actually we should spot blaze Oh oh god
blaze all right in here
these things are snipers huh all right
you know what you guys want you guys
want a Ravager too while we're at it oh
we're going to the nether boys we're
getting there Oh big boy boy what's
stray all right Oh
Oh bums there's a lot of big boys around
me helper there's 40 of these oh my gosh
they're backing out more so much trouble
Chris get away what's the difference
between this and a normal skeleton Karl
can you tell me right are you I don't
know oh they made me float oh so much
damage wait maybe if they make me fly I
can get to a good sniping spot make me
fly daddy my people need me
oh it's just the perfect time to where I
can't get out of the map lets me in the
middle Jamie I'm starting to not like
meeting in the middle with you come on
guys we just had we're just Joshin we're
just having fun
she may get fifty Shades of Minecraft oh
gosh oh oh three kills free XP guys push
[Music]
are you guys trying to push me in the
lava no my own friends are revolting
okay alright
oh oh we got a bunch of strength oh they
do a little bit of damage yeah a little
bit of damage how about these do these
damage oh no no I can't even shoot a my
ears are gonna do them yeah I killed a
gasps not again not again I'm in the
corner with the boy you always end up in
the corner I'm getting into the corner
what's an endermite uh I haven't seen
that's part of the new life thing oh
there's a lot of them now oh yo are
these rats Chris oh oh yeah the Rope
they do big damage they do big damage
and they're small I forgot we had levers
here you go
having a bunch of skeletons oh and a
bunch of that and whatever that is no oh
oh what I didn't know oh I'm gonna run
through it let's see you I can get cod
zombies has taught me one thing
alright guys how you doing Oh freaking
ones my donkey died oh you want a new
donkey leave here you go Chandler guys
this looks too easy
Taylor's just sitting on a donkey yes
yes why are you so fast on this donkey
you're just on your back leg
look at these baby donkeys they're so
cute oh no the creepers gonna kill them
all huh
all right all the boys do this I need to
come up with a really good plan how are
we gonna actually end this it's too easy
for them that's the last one that
remains go ahead and knock it out all
right all right all right me in the
middle me in the middle is that your
baby Chandler yes
oh yeah and I'll do it again
Caro come here throw your helmet on the
ground that was uncalled for now he's
gonna be able to get one shot in that
that's not a helmet nope throw your
helmet but you lost you lost your helmet
privilege $10,000 on the line and this
has been too easy
yeah agree you're about to have the
hardest round possible it is gonna be
sowing conceivably hard that none of you
will probably survive but all that
matters is that you out survive the
other two people oh do you guys know
what a wither is yes that's a box that's
a spawner
you put a spawner down Oh God my donkey
but it doesn't just end with the wither
it's only a growing me we have we have
some zombies why is it a growing me up
next I'm gonna spawn some gas stop why
is there more up next I'm gonna spawn
some wither skeleton yes I'm getting the
gas guys can somebody take care of the
wither that's only a growing me please I
feel like I got my own problem I can't
yes up next I'm gonna spawn some
soldiers whatever these boxes are all
right we're gonna put a lot of these
down up next I'm gonna spawn a ton of
slime oh I'm taking so much damage and I
have to just run there's a lot of slime
my arch-nemesis know the corner up next
I'm gonna spawn a husk I don't know what
that is did somebody get the wither
please and what's a phantom I need help
I can't hear anything for my next act
I'm gonna come over here I'm just gonna
mash all these buttons a bug stop it why
it's a bear the withers only on me AM
boom alright let's see how it's going oh
gosh oh yeah jump back down oh I took so
much damage I'm bout to die oh my gosh
alright here I think we need more wither
I think that yeah no I just
whether okay now it's anybody's game
there's a boil and your dragon in there
please all right I'm gonna spawn some
more creepers oh man a little boy oh my
god have I died am I going to heaven I'm
such a gamer right now is the answer
more wither no I can't hear anything the
withers are gonna kill everything oh all
right who will survive who will survive
oh my gosh Carl how'd you die I can't
even tell you how I died I can't hear
you melted right now alright Chris how
you doing I'm doing good I'm doing good
yeah you look like you're trying really
hard I'm sweating always have heart oh
really
I gotta go check on it before he dies
Chandler you got the done but hey you're
out
oh he's not happy I'm dizzy I'm poisoned
I'm everything in the book I'm gonna go
run bye Oh
you guys beside me the driver you're
okay my child what child the one that's
not here yet but will be here that's it
for this video make sure you subscribe
and I'll see you later
[Applause]